♪Music Starts♪
Air pollution is one of the most
urgent and critical problems
that humanity faces today.
Many activities that
are essential to our
progress, our economy,
and our well-being are
very unfortunately
associated with
generation of pollution.
These are manufacturing
industries, chemical industries,
oil and gas refining industries,
they all generate
a lot of pollutants
that need to be
removed or
destroyed before
they release their
exaust into the air.
To remove these pollutants,
catalytic converters are
currently introduced into the
exhaust lines.
In the heart of the catalytic
converter is a catalytic coating,
which contains precious metal
nano-particles,
which are the active ingredients
of the system.
The problem is that not all of
these nano-particles are
efficiently utilized.
Only a fraction of the nano-
particles are being exposed
to the exhaust pollutants,
and this is the most costly
ingredient of the system.
Catalytic converter producers
spend about 70-90% of their
total cost on precious metals.
Within, probably even
50 years, main sources
of platinum, palladium,
iridium, metals that are
used in catalytic
converters,
would go down or maybe
disappear completely.
So what we try to do is
to think about how to
optimize materials,
based on biological design, based on something
that nature has developed through millions
of years of evolution.
The Wyss Institute is supporting a broad range
of bio-inspired materials, devices, and approaches.
The design of our coatings is definitely
inspired by butterfly wings and it has the same
porous architecture.
If you look at its micro-
structure, it is structured in a
way that will allow the wing
to be aerodynamic, hydrophobic,
and not become heavy or sticky
in the rain.
And it also creates the
beautiful coloration of the
butterfly.
The butterfly actually doesn't
produce any pigments.
We realized we don't have to
invent any new chemistry,
or new materials, we can just
structure our materials
in a way that will allow much
more efficient use of the
precious metal nano-particles,
based on these bio-inspired
principles.
We can precisely put them at the
interface of the pore
and make them fully accessible
to the exhaust gasses.
This drammatically improves the
performance of these coatings,
making it much cheaper and
accessible.
What is really unique about our
technology is that it provides
a "plug and play" solution.
There is no need to modify
manufacturing processes,
our technology can be easily
adapted to the current
manufacturing processes.
I do think that this is a really
good example of an approach
that does both, that improves
cost and economic considerations
and actually purifies air
as the outcome of that.
We applied for the President's
Innovation Challenge and
have been preselected from over
200 teams to compete with
15 other teams within three
different categories.
It's a validation of your
business vision,
it's a validation of your
technology, already,
without even winning this prize.
And now we have "Open-
Track Runner Up":
"Air Crew"
♪Applause♪
And it's capable of bridging
this very difficult gap between
the conception of the idea, and
being able to commercialize it.
So, that process, being able to
connect that, to
build this bridge is the mission
of the Wyss Institute.
If we will see that this
technology has transferred into
products that make a substancial
positive influence
on the environment and society,
this will be the real
recognition.